let's just get right into it because
boys and girls we in a recession they're
lying we they keep saying we're not in a
recession but we were in a recession
what topics do you have for John I and
you to discuss together let's begin I'm
so sad but okay let's begin with the
rate hike
um The Impossible has been made possible
twice in a row uh it says what seemed
unfathomable unfathomable just six
months ago a 75 basis point rate hike by
the FED has now happened twice in a row
so why is this important and what does
it mean
they hiked interest rates because
inflation was high which is what you
would do the problem is they also were
hiking interest rates into a recession
which we'll get to in a second and so
naturally they started with we're going
to do 25 basis points then we're gonna
do 50. now doing 75. it's like if you
show up to a fight and uh during that
fight if all of a sudden some dude's
talking [ __ ] to you this is like the
street explanation of what the fed's
doing right now you show up to a street
fight and the guy in front of you you're
like you know what I'm gonna slap them
you slap them nothing happens the next
you're like you know what I'm gonna do I
think I'm gonna punch them and then you
punch them and then you're like damn
he's still standing then you have a
baseball bat and you hit him with a
baseball bat and then eventually you're
like yo this dude is Not Gonna Get
Knocked Down by any means that I have
that's what the fed's doing but rather
than the opponent being an individual
it's inflation they came out to 25 basis
points then 50. now that's 75 inflation
has been accelerating it does not matter
in the short term they have not been
effective in getting inflation down it's
actually gotten worse even though
they're raising interest rates John what
do you think when you see them
continuing to be aggressive with 75
basis point hikes it's exactly what they
said they were going to do right putting
this out in the market I was more
interested in the fact that Jerome
Powell had uh not much to say about the
indication of what they'll do in the
future of months right so this is the
pivotal point in my mind where you've
already raised interest rates enough uh
what they think is enough as of right
now they wanted if they should have done
100 they should have done 100 whatever
but you've raised it enough so what do
you do from now do you raise it at the
next meeting do you call an emergency
meeting in a month and try to raise it
again if inflation's still high if
inflation comes down do you start
reversing cores what happens from here I
think is more important than what
happened yesterday simply because we all
knew the rate hikes were coming we were
talking about yesterday being priced
into the market uh in some cases so it's
not surprising the next meeting is uh
not next month but the month after
September and uh we'll see what they do
but as of right now it ain't looking so
hot what's going on with GDP stuff
GDP has not grown the economy is
expected to have barely grown last
quarter and it may have contracted I
think it yeah Goldman Goldman Sachs
expects a one percent increase and
that's weird
I mean at the highest level if you're a
market forecaster if you're an economist
if you're even some of the Talking Heads
if you're a politician Central Banker
they all were predicting positive GDP
growth right so it's one thing if you
say hey look this really complex system
you know what I think it's going to be
0.4 growth and it comes in at 0.3 or 0.6
or even 0.2 or 0.5
but instead you say it's going to be
positive and it comes in negative well
it's only a 50 50. like if I send you a
is a positive or negative you said
positive it was negative you're wrong
Goldman sees positive Moody says it's
going to be one percent negative no it
is negative what it was it came out this
morning at 8 30. yeah yeah no this this
article was saying what they were saying
that's what I'm saying Goldman Sachs
always people are saying is going to be
positive it's gonna be positive they're
wrong wrong it was negative so point
nine percent negative annualized GDP
growth two consecutive quarters of
negative GDP growth means we're in a
recession
although John's laughing they're gonna
Gaslight you they are gas this is the
definition of gaslighting here's how
this plays out folks we had negative GDP
uh GDP growth in q1 they saw the GDP
numbers earlier this week why is it two
or three days before the GDP numbers
come out that would meet the technical
definition of a recession you started to
see blog posts go up talking points
shared oh recession isn't really in two
consecutive quarters what
if somebody had the courage in the
journalistic circles to sit there and
say Define a recession
somebody asked Jerome Powell that
question somebody asked Janet Yellen
somebody asked President Biden somebody
asked the white house uh uh speaker
person
somebody asked them okay cool it's not
two consecutive quarters what is a
recession what is the definition of a
recession you know what they're gonna
say
oh there's this organization they decide
they're making it up they they now are
saying there is no definition to a
recession
their claiming is
uh I think that it's a recession that's
not how it works
what is the definition now if you claim
that it is not too consecutive negative
growth GDP quarters what is it
why is no one asking that question have
they not defined it they say there's no
definition now
that's what they're saying they're
saying there is no definition we just
have this random organization that again
anyone here name me one person that
works at the National Bureau of economic
research
anyone anyone Bueller Bueller I feel
like I'm in a class right now nobody
knows who works there
and so now all of a sudden they get to
just randomly claim what a recession is
come on come on
what do you think I think it doesn't
even matter I don't care if if you tell
me the recession is two negative
quarters three negative course four
negative quarters things are bad that is
what matters I love them change the
definition of recession they're
gaslighting people yeah duh it's the
White House of course they're going to
do that when things are bad and uh
sediment is down and less than 25
percent of people actually trust the
government yeah duh they're gonna
Gaslight people but it doesn't even
matter look at the inflation numbers
look at the housing numbers look at the
uh non-farm payroll numbers like look at
the actual numbers that matter and GDP
matters but guess what it doesn't matter
in the grand scheme of things whether
you call it a recession whether you say
we're in bad times the Great Depression
whatever you want to call it it doesn't
matter the numbers matter somebody said
John's rent skyrocketing he knows he
knows that this [ __ ] is bad yeah I don't
care if you say go to the grocery store
go to the grocery store try to renew
your lease try to go and get a new
mortgage just go live your life and try
to tell me I talked to the guy at the
coffee shop every single week I ask them
how is business
down week over week they're losing
business how are prices up you're
telling me that things are going so well
we're not in a recession you can point
all you want to unemployment numbers you
can point to consumer spending consumer
spending is softening unemployment is
starting to creep up it was 3.4 3.5 now
it's 3.6 starting to creep up slowly
also on top of that we got 40-year high
inflation and worse the worst thing is
actually the thing you can't measure
which is the psychology the psychology
of consumers consumers no all the data
they're looking at is backwards looking
that's what was happening
how many of you are spending less money
now how many of you are preparing four
bad times
my question is who is the White House
trying to convince that there is not a
recession because I don't think that the
average consumer is necessarily paying
attention to that and believing it when
they do go to the grocery store pay
their rent and see Scott uh prices
Skyrocket we live in a world where they
don't have to be right they just have to
create doubt
all they have to do is create the
conversation
if they just simply say oh that's not a
recession
it's like the Putin price hike
how is it that Vladimir Putin's the one
who raised all the prices but now our
politicians are taking uh Victory laps
because the prices are going down
if you had so much control over the
price why didn't you keep the price from
going up
again it just goes back to I understand
the incentives like the if you're a
politician that's what you have to do
you can't actually do anything the
politicians don't control monetary
policy they can't go and force price
controls on people uh without any sort
of backlash they don't have anything to
do with the gasoline prices all these
stuffs what they do they just talk
they just have to try to control the
narrative because if you control the
narrative that's better than doing
nothing
that's it well well well what's up with
the Choco Taco so I can't say those two
words together I can say them separately
it's a weird thing I don't know why okay
let me say it really slowly the Choco
Taco I gotta bring this up just because
you you know you know me
I'm OCD like and and the reason is is
like chocolate Taco choco tell us what's
happening and then I'm gonna tell you
about a taco that is gonna blow your
mind oh okay
um so this product is being discontinued
by Klondike is that how you say it
um over the past few years we have
experienced an unprecedented spike in
demand across our portfolio and have had
to make very tough decisions to ensure
availability of our portfolio Nationwide
in otherwise they said nothing this is a
word salad they are just discontinuing
Choco Taco after 40 years oh I said it
you see okay
um but yeah so then our friend Alexis
Ohanian who's a venture capitalist he
said I'd like to buy the rights to your
Choco Taco and keep it from melting away
from future Generations childhoods said
Reddit co-founder Alexis Ohanian do we
think he has a shot
what are you doing I'm pulling this up
if I can find out how to uh how to do it
he's on Tick Tock right now guys I I
somehow got here off Google uh I don't
know how to use tick tock so I'm a
little confused but just hold on one
second uh go ahead John what do you
think and then uh I will uh
I've never eaten a Choco Taco what um I
will say if there was enough demand for
it they wouldn't have canceled the
product so everyone who's complaining
should have bought more Choco Tacos like
that's the thing and people discontinue
products that they're not making money
on or not making enough money on right
and not enough people are buying
chocolate tacos the thing's been around
for decades and clearly there's demand
has gone down for the Choco Taco you say
you eat it congratulations well you
better eat it while you can because it's
going away do I think someone should buy
like Alexis or honey and buy the Choco
Taco IP or the recipe or whatever you
want to say yeah he should because if
you like it you can still make it you
can still make money on it it's not
going to die overnight but uh yeah this
doesn't matter to me at all he he loves
Choco Tacos I mean they're they're just
all time like if you were to rank ice
cream where do you eat the gas stations
yeah I mean that like chocolate is not
someone you like order you have it at
your house or go get a chocolate Taco
it's a definite Amma gonna be a fat ass
today and make an Impulse person
purchase as I walk through the gas
station that's that that their whole
business was built on America is fat and
is susceptible to impulse purchases
that was the Choco Taco and that and
school lunches if they were making money
they wouldn't cancel it well I'm saying
if they were making enough money they
would never cancel that I don't know
because here's why there's a video now
that uh uh cultural appropriation has
been occurring I'm not saying that this
has anything to do with the Choco Taco
but it is related to it you guys know
corporate greed just as much as I am
uh Matt can we play this video real
quick oh God John you're going you're
going to just actually die this woman is
a genius this is content genius
no no go down uh to the other uh this
one yeah
oh hold on one second hold on I call
these my sausage tacos that I have been
obsessed with lately I made it up all by
myself and they're so good
okay so first you're gonna take these
really cute fluffy tortillas and you're
just gonna open them up they kind of do
it for you and then I'm gonna take this
American kind of Crema
thing I'm not really sure but this is
what I use coat it okay and then I'm
gonna take the sausage plop that in and
then I like to top mine with this
American
and then also this I'm not quite sure
how I pronounce it I think it's gonna
starred mustard I got it all at Trader
Jose because it's super accessible there
is my sausage taco
make sure y'all blow this up so it gets
super popular and then it can start
showing up in our stores and that way we
can start paying like 25 for one of
these
[Music]
because what she basically did is like
all these stupid Americans are trying to
uh take authentic food from other
cultures and they talk about it they
sound stupid
so smart just put a mirror up to the
world people sort of pay attention John
doesn't look very impressed no you're
not impressed you didn't think that was
funny I couldn't hear it I couldn't hear
it
no she she said uh that they're sausage
tacos and then she said oh look they
have these tortillas uh they just open
up for you and then she called the hot
dog a sausage and then she said uh
Trader Joe's Trader Jose's yeah all
right all right all right what's the
next thing Mega Millions jackpot has
cracked
no grand prize tickets were sold for the
Tuesday night drawing it's now at 1.02
billion or a cash option it's over a
billion 600 it's over a billion of 602.5
million wait does that mean that yeah we
got to go John and I are gonna go buy
tickets today if you get it you have to
pay half in taxes so you only end up
with 602 million only
I'll make everyone a deal right now what
I'm gonna go today John's gonna hold me
accountable we're gonna buy I'm gonna
buy 10 tickets wait can you get me one
I'll buy 10 tickets here's the deal I'm
gonna buy 10 tickets
and if we win
I will take every single dollar that we
get
and I'll donate that [ __ ]
and I'll let this audience here pick
where we donated oh
I like it I'll buy 10 tickets if we win
hand out what they call Hand in My Heart
what if you what if you donated a
billion dollar jackpot I don't care I'd
don't if I don't
go take 45 of it from the people 602
yeah okay well there you go well
wouldn't it be amazing for the last
lunch money show to hit that jackpot
it's the fourth largest jackpot in
history the lottery is one of the
biggest
um
scams I'll call it in in America they
push the lottery on people that cannot
afford to lose money playing the lottery
hold on I disagree I don't say we should
give it to the chat
I disagree that it's the biggest scam
because I went on scholarship to
University of Georgia because of the
Lottery lottery so the Georgia Lottery
no I'm talking about like the the
lottery Mega Millions well yeah in some
states it does but this is but this is
part of the scam education NC Education
Lottery 11 goes to education is they
take a portion of it and they do some
good with it it's kind of like sometimes
there's uh there's some companies not
all companies but some companies like yo
we sell a product by the way if you buy
it uh they'll like do something and like
sure like it does have some positive
impact but it's more marketing than it
is like the impact kind of like that it
does more I think it does more harm than
good better than calling it a scam I
think it's a tax on dumb people well
skin is a hard word because it makes it
seem like it's not real or yeah
I'm telling you you got 300 choices you
have personal choice you walk in you buy
the ticket like it's very clear that
logs are off people supported my
education that's true
dinosaur footprints dating back a
hundred million years have been
discovered in southwestern China after a
woman who was dining at a restaurant in
the courtyard happened to spot look at
these massive Footprints and she's like
hold on aren't those dinosaur footprints
from 100 million years ago and they were
I mean it's an insane photo it's clear
that those are how they know look at
this so okay so how do they know come on
right you're telling me no one ever saw
these before I never saw that so there's
a table right there no one was ever like
yo what's those big ass holes in the
ground wow apparently not what they yes
the dirt was only removed about a year
ago in the restaurant okay okay they're
being removed is a big natural look of
the uneven Stone so he left it untouched
instead of leveling it with cement and
they I think I think they've like ran
these fossils through something and they
confirmed it is hold on yeah they use
the 3D scanner to confirm the discovery
it's a sword all right I I thought that
this had been there for a couple years
if it's only been there for one year
still in 12 months almost like yo look
at that big ass footprint isn't that
crazy that's really cool 100 million
years old
finding stuff now that's been around for
a while 100 million years yeah I don't
really know what's going on here uh what
I'll say is I don't believe it until
someone proves it I don't know what
these creators in the ground they got
going on you want to know my favorite
thing is Holly knows 100 million not 99.
yeah well it's not 101 million years
they have a 3D scanner it's not a 100
million and uh in one year
I didn't know they don't you know my
favorite dinosaur it's not really a
dinosaur the uh uh gold-plated uh was a
mammoth at uh I know it's not a real
dinosaur but like whatever that's fine
that or uh what was the the Koch brother
he donated a dinosaur to uh the Museum
of Natural Science I think in uh New
York history Natural History is that
what it was something like that but we
that's how you know you're rich if you
own a dinosaur you don't have any last
words for the people no I'm just gonna
turn it over to you what would you like
to say to everyone
can you hear can you hear right now or
no can I hear you don't have any ears in
no uh they're playing funeral music oh
that's so sad in the eyes
of an Angel that's not a funeral
is that not a funeral music thank you
guys for watching um we'll see here
tomorrow appreciate yourself
appreciate your I mean I will see you on
the internet so I appreciate your
support of the show thank you very much
uh look forward to talking with you guys
on the internet soon
perfect John and they're playing the
music in the background too you got a
soft voice
all right